here he's fantastic please give it up
for mr. Hans Kim everybody come on live
here
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys gonna be here in his hot
skin and we lost 1/5 of the audience I'm
a little bummed but we're gonna soldier
on cheeky ketchup someone give her the
sparknotes you know catch her up on all
the comings and goings
my name is Collins Kim and I used to
date a woman it was pretty epic time of
my life
and she was really into yoga and choke
sex and obviously I was just over here
like do you enjoy breathing or not like
make up your mind all right
Millennials this is [ __ ] crazy I I
love dating you know I'm single right
now I'd get to be my soul mate I'm
beginning to think maybe it's her fault
she needs to get out more
she seems like a loser
I think I can do better I know the
ladies don't think I could ever have sex
with a dude sorry sorry guys I am sexist
now I've never looked at a beautiful
woman and been like she is gorgeous but
is there a version of her that's bigger
area and less kindness
I like stick that in my butthole never
happens trans [ __ ] hello welcome back
we're all one again we got all seventeen
of us here in terms of drinks you're in
charge of American dish name I'm in
charge move hilarities a great comedic
is catching you up as very hilarious for
two minutes it's like here's my next
joke it's about capitalism isn't wherein
finished let me tell you this guy on
stage that you don't nothing about
I think capitalism is great you know if
you want to do it but don't make
everyone play your stupid game
I like fortnight I don't make a grandma
play and take away our house if she
loses Wall Street bros and all right
okay just relax
I think communism is not the answer but
I do think that people are very biased
against it you know people in America
will be like communism never works as if
they didn't spend billions of dollars
and kill millions of people to make sure
it wouldn't work
I remember being on Cambodia Panama Cuba
you guys are a pretty anxious about an
outworking communism never works because
whenever people control the means of
production their democratically elected
leaders mysteriously died and small
rebel group always clangs automatic
weapons look they're hitting themselves
we've conveyed them a big stupid okay so
judging from that you I guess you guys
are
what is this an American comedy show
America look hamburger cheeseburger
Americans I am Korean hello you know the
first time I went to a foreign country
was when I was born in America that's
sort of my life you know it's hard for
me man
I like to eat General Tso's chicken you
know at my Asian friends are like
judging me they're like plunging like
General Tso's chicken is like a shitty
Americanized version of something up
technically Asian like yeah but semi my
favorite movies rush hour 3 I am Asian
[Music]
eyes or the mouth Chinese I'm from a
province in china called south korea so
it makes the japan promise we're getting
made fun of a lot people make fun of us
because we like to eat canines and that
shocks people quizzing but I understand
because an American dog treated like
family members but in Asia we treat our
family members like family members
cultural difference in America you know
you bad dogs but in Asia instead of by
animals we love our grandpa
little things unless she's a baby girl
my Stacy throw her in the river
what Jarboe away rules are rules that we
stick to them we're agent it's hard to
date as an ancient man and multi-station
women are beautiful that everyone thinks
Asian men are beautiful which doesn't
even make any sense I mean how do you
think women are created me [ __ ] okay
I'm a crucial part of the sexy process
please stop trying to get me if you have
sex with me our children will be very
beautiful
half of them the other half will be
great engineers oh that's important too
I am NOT a racist person okay I need
people to going to nail the first race
it doesn't hurt a bit behavior more
their skin I hate people for their souls
I did have a bit of a Rachel moment
earlier this week I was on a plane and I
saw do doing a book in Arabic which kind
of freaked me out but then I found him
hold the corner of the book and put it
away and I was like oh that guy's got
future plans
[Laughter]
don't do it both up in the middle of a
book you know you guys can't die not
know what happens
I love the Black Panther movie at the
bells great movie because they gave
black children a hero they could finally
woke up to and not just someone like
Martin Luther King jr. mathematics
Harriet Tubman brother Harvey Jackie
Robinson Abahlali or Michael Jordan or
Vietnam it doesn't end Allah or I did
something where George wanted the carpet
or not further goodness
now they have a fake person that does
like a cat so congratulations you made
it thank a deer so he's an asian
schoolgirl what are they going to come
out with the yellow pad or is our movie
Kung Fu Panda doesn't count
that's Jack Black and the cartoon is a
panda it's gotta be an Asian
looking sexy it strong or weak no
anyways not not really doing that great
in my life right now I live in an
automobile a van a luxury welcome home
and it's a pretty hard date you know
because a little bit until you get them
inside of it initially it's all about
the push
the white man but don't jump it I it's
hard to date so even if like a tinder
date goes well what usually ends up
happening is we go for a drive until I
can work up the courage to tell her we
arrived 45 minutes ago so that's just
sort of bad life I live in a band so I
can pursue comedy full-time so if you
didn't think I was funny I'm sorry I'm
terribly hard I'm all-in
oh I know there's someone in the back
like yeah that was funny but not living
you're being funny could've written that
joke in an apartment buddy why don't you
try being a human for once okay okay the
reason I was in the van is because
others sleep in a car be awake at your
job cannibalism
I don't understand people who ate
immigrants okay these people like you
know was taking all my money the people
with less money than me they got on
bunny what about the people with the
money maybe they have your money yes
again I'm an immigrant I'm pretty good
at math so what's the deal with my
dating life okay let's not talk about
that right now
I'm a little sensitive I would rather
talk to you guys about this big about
your paid gigolo they're gonna see this
movie it's just a hoot and a holler you
guys should watch it it's quite comedic
thank you later
that's a joke I know it's something a
personal you guys I don't understand the
phrase don't drop the soap I mean it
should really be don't pick up the soap
you think about it
I think drop it for some reason why it's
depending over where they really catch
it even if you don't drop the soap
you're still gonna get raped you're just
gonna have really clean handle it
happens what is working for these rape
is like man I want to get that
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]